This is an exciting
moment for AI here in Canada.
We are facing a historic opportunity
and responsibility
to harness the potential of AI
to drive economic growth
and improve social outcomes.
Canada is AI’s birthplace,
and I'm proud to say
that much of the seminal work
happened and continues to happen
right here in Toronto.
Among Canada's
early investments was the founding
of the Vector Institute,
led by our Chief
Scientific Advisor Geoffrey Hinton.
With the support
of the Government of Canada,
the Government of Ontario,
and industry partners,
Vector helped make Ontario a hub of AI
excellence that has spilled out
across Canada,
leading to the tremendous growth
of our AI industry.
Last year alone, more than $8.6B
in venture capital
funding was invested in Canadian
AI companies.
That's 30% of all Canadian VC activity.
That is a stunning number
for an industry that didn't even exist
less than a decade ago.
Generative AI is already transforming
the way we work and play.
Canada is home to many generative AI
focused companies.
At Vector,
we’re highly focused
on helping Canadian industry
adopt and commercialize AI.
We work with our industry partners
to give their teams unique
access to expert
researchers, exceptional training,
and a sandbox environment
that allows them to experiment with new
AI technologies.
They know that in partnering with Vector,
they gain unparalleled access
to an AI talent pool
that really sets the bar
for the rest of the world.
AI holds tremendous
promise to improve our daily
lives, our society,
and our economic prospects
as long as we do it responsibly.
This moment in AI in Canada really
excites me.